und das dümmste ist einfach die gucci
hose ich weiß es ist keine gucci hose
und soll auch kein fake davon sein ich
habe einfach diese eingegeben und musste
diese hose kaufen ich glaube ich sitze
gerade fast drauf an die das schuh
herren ein ja wenn ich dann so ein schuh
sehe so dann würde ich mir halt holen
auch wenn das selbstverständlich
schlimmste qualität ist die man sich nur
vorstellen kann
was genau bei herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut ich freue mich
heute auf das video sehr viele von euch
fragen sich wahrscheinlich war da nicht
noch irgendwas mit seinem handy das du
bestellt hast ja das stimmt
und eigentlich sollte das video dazu
heute kommen nur dieses scheiß handy ist
immer noch nicht da wenn ich mir hier
den bestell vollauf anschaut steht aber
es kommen bis zum 23
und es müsste eigentlich schon längst da
sein wird ihr gesagt das wurde am 14
dritter also vor acht tagen oder genau
vor acht tagen ist das in frankfurt
angekommen und von frankfurt hin
das hat mir normalerweise an einem tag
aber das handy ist immer noch nicht da
ist kommt spätestens übermorgen an an
die wir nicht wissen worum es geht es
geht um ein handy das sich über wunsch
bestellt habe für 30 euro und nicht
essen wollte ob das gut ist oder scheiße
beziehungsweise ob es überhaupt
einigermaßen funktioniert wie es letztes
mal auch schon gemacht habe problem ist
nur ich war heute haben zu meinen eltern
weil wir in den skiurlaub fahren und ja
dann kommt das video dazu erst in
frühestens einer halb wochen weil ich
das handy wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
bekommen vor deswegen habe ich mir für
heute überlegt es sind trotzdem zwei
weitere produkte noch angekommen
die würde ich euch gar nicht
vorenthalten zeige ich euch gleich dabei
handelt es sich einmal um diese ps4
dockingstation für zwei ps4 controller
gleichzeitig glaube ich für vier euro
und das dümmste ist einfach die gucci
hose ich weiß es ist keine gute und soll
auch kein fake davon sein ich habe
einfach gutes eingegeben und musste
diese hose kaufen ich glaube ich sitze
gerade fast drauf leute diese
jogginghose ist ungefähr vor einer woche
angekommen hat glaube ich sieben euro
gekostet da will ich jetzt gar nicht
mehr kennen preis aber das ist wirklich
mit abstand die hässlichste und am
schlimmsten aussehens jogginghose die
ich in meinem ganzen leben gesehen habe
ich zeige euch sofort eine aber ohne
willst anziehen kann man die auf keinen
fall aber gepackt erstmal das hieraus
und bevor ihr euch fragt ja
was machst du heute eigentlich jetzt
vielleicht auch schon am titel gelesen
wir bestellen heute weitere produkte
allerdings heute nicht zufällig sondern
einfach die sachen die ich cool finde
und die ich gerne mal ausprobieren würde
ja ich will das eigentlich auch mal ganz
cool und wenn ihr trotzdem noch
vorgehabt auch ein paar zufällig
bestellen lassen doch nach oben da das
machen wir auch noch 2006 wir machen so
leute also bei der ersten sache haben
wir hier diese dockingstation gekauft
für fünf euro kann man halt anscheinend
2 playstation controller gleichzeitig
auch dann finde ich es eigentlich den
kauf der sich für mich sogar
ich würde sagen wir bauen das einfach
mal kurz auf ist auch ziemlich schnell
gemacht hier tut man dann wahrscheinlich
dass kabel rein so leute wie man sehen
kann das leuchtet schon mal ich teste
jetzt mal ob das auch lebt also ich muss
wirklich sagen ich bin durch das mal
kurz ein wenn man das zum beispiel auch
meine playstation stellt das sieht echt
stylisch aus und dafür fünf euro kann
ich wirklich fünf sterne geben kann man
das hier machen keine ahnung das war die
erste sache also wenn ihr mal das
problem habe dass eure playstation
controller nicht aufgeladen sind holt
euch einfach sowas ist günstig
funktioniert geil jetzt kommen aber
kurze hose ich muss mich mal kurz
umziehen seid ihr bereit für die hose
schaut euch diese hose mal an ich gehe
mal ein bisschen weiter weg
ich sehe eins zu eins aus wie ein clown
die ist einfach viel zu weit wenn man
sie jetzt so hoch zieht im sommer dann
finde ich dir sogar eigentlich stylish
aber sonst kann man hier auf keinen fall
draußen anziehen
ich sehe aus wie ein clown im zirkus
auftreten der schnitt von der hose ist
katastrophal und dass dieses zeichen
hier soll keine ahnung leute schreibt
meine kommentare bewertet mal die hose
von 1 bis 10 was sagt ihr kann man die
anziehen oder kann man ihn nicht ziehen
das einzig positive an der hose ist sie
ist relativ bequem ja soviel zu den
sachen mehr habe ich leider nicht
bekommen ich warte immer noch sehr
gespannt auf das handy hier auch schon
eben gesagt würde ich sagen heute
bestellen wir einfach mal alles das was
ich haben möchte
es wird natürlich wirklich bestellt und
dann wenn es da ist werde ich es auch
ausprobieren funktioniert das ist das
geil kann man das empfehlen oder halt
nicht erkennt ihr mittlerweile wie es
abläuft und ich würde sagen wir gar
nicht lange da waren wir fangen sofort
an so leute wir sind auf wunsch
ich habe mir gedacht hier oben gibt es
verschiedene kategorien und es gibt die
kategorie beliebt und ich würde sagen
schau jetzt einfach mal was ich finde
was ich gerne haben würde und dann wird
eingekauft haben wir zum beispiel schon
wieder so eine smart watch ich habe
meine für 16 euro gekauft und die hier
kostet 28 dollar
und irgendwie sehen die komplett gleich
aus das heißt ich glaube ich habe zwölf
euro gespart
hier haben wir dann handy für 31 euro
okay sonst habe ich ja schon bestellt
kopfhörer
das mache ich habe letztens mein vater
ist zum geburtstag kopfhörer geschenkt
und das waren wirklich eigentlich gut
und ich habe mich im laden ein bisschen
informiert und so wenn man vernünftige
kopfhörer kaufen möchte dann sollte man
das schon gerne mal so 60 70 für
ausgeben mindestens diese kosten jetzt
13 euro und ob die gut sind
wir nehmen einfach mal gold und weiß wie
immer fünf sterne resort abgestimmt
kurze wartezeit einfache bedienung und
super klang für den preis unschlagbar
gerne wieder also die erste hammer
mitgenommen hier haben wir eine
goldkette ich nehme einfach mal das
größte was geht das ist kostenlos da
kommt warum nicht
kaufen was ist das denn 5 mm led ensco
alter l das ding kostet fünf euro
ok jetzt wahrscheinlich 15 euro sechs
euro und das ist eine kamera die man an
das handy stecken kann
an der kamera ist ein langes kabel und
man kann halt gucken ob irgendwas im
abfluss drin ist oder so geil man das
will ich testen kaufen was ich mir auch
gestern mal gedacht habe ich habe
wirklich noch nicht viele schuhe für den
sommer ich hab zwar eigentlich viele
schuhe viele davon sind aber echt
dreckig und immer den winter also wenn
man dann hört man mit den rausgeht
werden die extrem schmutzig und ich
wollte mir noch ein paar neue sommers
will kaufen deswegen würde ich sagen
gucke ich jetzt einfach mal nach schuhen
für herren so wenn ich dann so einen
schuh sehe der neuen euro kostet wenn
ich jetzt eine frage würde und mir das
bildinhalten würde alex schätzt vietoris
der schuh wirklich locker sagen so 70
eur 9 euro ist verdammt wenig wir nehmen
einfach mal scheiße doch gibt es in
meiner größe nennen einfach mal einen 43
wir nehmen einfach mal in braun und in
den warenkorb der schule erinnert mich
ein bisschen oder eigentlich voll an die
wenn sie eigentlich noch ganz gut
aussehen ich würde sagen ich gebe
einfach nochmal adidas schuh herren ein
ja wenn ich dann so ein schuh sehe
sondern würde ich mir halt holen auch
wenn das ist wahrscheinlich die
schlimmste qualität ist die man sich nur
vorstellen kann wobei man das ja auch
nicht mal zu 100 prozent sagen kann wir
haben hier sportschuh für damen und
herren ich nehme einfach auch mal in 43
wähle die farbe weiß was verkauft dann
nehmen wir die farbe grau 120 euro für
so ein paar sneaker kann man auf keinen
fall meckern
jetzt bin ich mal auf die qualität
gespannt das kommt auch in den warenkorb
jetzt habe ich gerade
also ich dachte erst das wäre irgendwie
vielleicht eine handy hülle oder
irgendwas anderes fürs handy für 19 euro
wir haben hier amazing 5.0 frauen ob
d'accord 8 megapixel kamera bluetooth
16gb smartphone mit kopfhörern also das
ist alles daran halten der ladestationen
kopfhörer
ein akku und ein handy das aussieht wie
ein iphone aber von android betrieben
wird und wenn man sich mal die
beschreibung anguckt steht da auch
wirklich dass ein smartphone dabei ist
das ist nochmal fast die hälfte von dem
handy was ich letztes mal gefunden habe
und das handy letztes mal hat ja schon
nur 30 euro kostet ich dachte günstiger
geht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr also
leute hier immer aufpassen die haben das
handy wenn man hier noch nicht
ausgewählt hat bei 19 euro wenn man
schwarz aus welt liegt es auch noch bei
19 euro ist allerdings ausverkauft wenn
man weiss auswählt liegt es 232 euro man
kann es kaufen wenn man gut ausfüllt ist
es ausverkauft und liegt nur bei 19 euro
und jetzt lass mich raten 32 euro
hier muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen bevor
ich das kaufen warte ich erst einmal ab
wie das andere handys seien könne man
sicher noch einige und sagen okay ich
teste das auch noch aber ich tu's
erstmal wieder weg so wir gehen mal
wieder zu beliebt zurückzuholen ein
bisschen runterkommen das ist dann so
eine sache wo ich sagen muss
durex kondomen 12 kondome für 11 euro
also die kriegt man im laden deutlich
billiger und kondome übrig bestellen
ob diese wirklich halten das würde ich
jetzt nicht riskieren körper was wir
hier haben und hier kosten die plötzlich
schon neun euro thema was ist das für
eine rose streetfashion hip hop man
alter guckt euch das mal ich verstehe
diese leute nicht die solche engen hosen
anziehen
danke ich habe mich falls sonntag in
skiurlaub und ich hätte gerne einen red
bull
das ding ist es gibt halt wirklich so'n
scheiß helm hier okay wir geben einfach
mal nur wird wohl ein
wir haben ja eine red bull skibrille für
19 euro also hier fahren sonntag los
nicht dass es gerade am mittwoch das
heißt in vier tagen wird natürlich knapp
aber ich bestelle es einfach mal zu
meinen eltern hin und guckt ob
vielleicht die brille noch ankommt
ansonsten liegen wir es gerade bei 138
euro 91 euro kosten und 47 euro versand
wir haben ja immer die red bull brille
die schuhe noch mal schuhe
dieses ding was abflüsse besichtigt dann
die goldkette kopfhörer und das hier
habe ich irgendwie letztes mal hat schon
gehabt das braucht man gar nicht ach so
ja raus okay jetzt liegen wir nur noch
bei 113 euro ist aber trotzdem einiges
an geld ich bin gespannt ich freue mich
natürlich wenn das handy an kommt heute
wenn ich noch mal zufällig bestellen zu
lassen
nach oben da wir sehen uns dann
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder weithin
1600 prozent zufällig bestellen freut
sich auf das handy video und janácek
snapshot und instagram auf jeden fall ab
worauf instagram werde ich jetzt in
nächster zeit vier posten auch aus dem
skiurlaub ich freue mich schon sehr und
yahoo